(upbeat instrumental music)
- What's up everybody, Michael here.
Now it shouldn't be a surprise
that we're obsessed with adult animation
and with how seemingly silly
shows like "Rick and Morty",
"South Park", and "BoJack Horseman"
can actually teach us a lot
about some pretty serious stuff,
from depression, de-gentrification,
to emotionally processing that
your mom might be a clone.
But we've yet to touch on
the adult animation show
that's not afraid to throw
some meat on the grill,
"King of the Hill".
This slice of Texan suburban
life ran for over a decade
in the late '90s and early two 2000s,
and while it holds a special place
in the hearts of its fans, it
hasn't commanded the same grip
on the cultural conversation
as its contemporaries,
like "The Simpsons" or "Family Guy",
and that may be because the
hill family and their neighbors
aren't often exploring
lofty philosophical ideas
over their cold cans of American lager.
There's no alcoholic grandpa
to give us nihilistic
musings on the universe,
and none of the episodes
end with someone saying...
- But I've learned something today.
- [Michael] In fact, the
show's creator, Mike Judge,
has said that he specifically avoids
injecting any political
messaging into his work.
We'd argue that "Office
Space" is definitely
a political film, but who are
we to disagree with Mr. Judge?
- I'm tired of being pushed around!
Aren't you?
- Yes, Peter, but I'm not
going to do anything illegal.
- Illegal? Samir, this is America!
- [Michael] But does
that mean that the show
is completely apolitical?
Is it even possible for a television show
to skirt politics entirely?
After all, king at the hell's characters
are often thrown into
very political situations,
and their world views are
shaped by their experiences.
- So I see you finally got
Luanne involved in politics.
That's good.
(hammering)
Ass.
- The people united...
- Boo. (speaking gibberish).
- Boo!
- Commie go home!
- And it's safe to say there are very few
television characters
who are as consistent
and steadfast in their
values as Hank Hill.
- What if somebody wants theirs well done?
- We ask them politely,
yet firmly, to leave.
- It's easy to read the
show simply as a caricature
of conservative families in
Texas, and plenty of people do.
But is there a deeper
message hidden in the musings
of these working-class sweethearts?
Let's find out on this Wisecrack edition
on King of the Hill: Deep or Dumb?
For the uninitiated or
forgetful, "King of the Hill"
depicts a fictional central
Texas suburb called Arlen,
and specifically the Hill family,
consisting of Hank, Peggy
and their son, Bobby.
Hank is an all-American man's man.
He was a teen football star,
married his high school sweetheart,
and settled down in his hometown.
Unlike other animated sitcom dads
with names like Homer or Peter,
Hank isn't portrayed as an oafish slob
who's barely keeping his family intact.
Instead, he's a principled,
loving patriarch
who serves as a moral center,
not only for his family
but also for his community.
He believes in hard work, family values,
and, of course, the supremacy of propane
over any other fuel source.
- You brought charcoal into our house!
- I didn't know what it was!
Luanne asked me to hold it for her!
I thought it was drugs!
- [Michael] Much of the
central conflict of the show
comes from Hank's stalwart
ways clashing against
the world's changing social
and political landscape.
Conflicts can ensue from everything
from sex education in public schools...
- What? Sexual education?
Where'd you get this?
- [Michael] To eco-friendly toilets.
(toilet flushing)
- Still?
- [Michael] That's not to say that Hank
is overtly conservative.
At the very least, he seems
to believe in climate change.
- It's already 110 in the summer,
and if it gets one degree
hotter, I'm gonna kick your ass!
- [Michael] And he
acknowledges that Americans
stole their land from indigenous peoples.
- I agree that stealing
Indian's land was wrong.
Can't you agree that
eating people is wrong?
- [Michael] It may be this
moderate political positioning
that makes Hank such
an endearing character
to those all over the political spectrum,
and why some critics have
called "King of the Hill"
the last bipartisan TV comedy.
So is the show trying to extol the values
of moderate conservatism?
Well, not exactly.
Hank's behavior isn't guided
by his political leanings
or his religious beliefs,
even though he is a God-fearing man.
- I know God's up there,
and he knows I'm smack dab in
the middle of the second pew.
- [Michael] Instead, he
tends to make decisions
based on a combination
of conventional wisdom
and an innate sense of right and wrong.
Now, this doesn't always
lead to the correct decision.
In fact, Hank nearly misses out
on voting in a presidential election
because his candidate
had a flimsy handshake.
- Oh my God!
His handshake!
(dramatic orchestral music)
It's limp!
- [Michael] As many times
as Hank is portrayed
as his family and friend's moral guide,
he is just as often put in situations
where he has to compromise
some of these values
in order to live a fulfilling
life and care for his family.
This is especially true when it comes
to his relationship with his son, Bobby.
- That boy ain't right.
- [Michael] Despite Hank's best efforts
to pass down his brand of masculinity,
Bobby is most fulfilled when
he's performing prop comedy,
or stage magic, or ventriloquism.
His attempts to push Bobby into sports
or other, more masculine-coded pursuits
only deteriorates their relationship.
These moments often cause Hank
to reflect on his relationship
with his own father,
who he begins to realize
might not have been
the best role model.
- You know how I was raised,
what my father's like.
- I got my shins blown off
by a Japan man's machine gun!
So don't come crying to
me with your problems!
- [Michael] Most of these episodes end
with Hank feeling content
that at least Bobby has found
his own niche in society,
even if that means taking on roles
that Hank considers more feminine,
like when Bobby shows an
aptitude for cooking and cleaning
after taking a home economics class.
- If Bobby learns to cook
and clean for himself,
what's his motivation to ever get married?
- This speaks to what may
be the underlying theme
of the whole series.
Time and time again, Hank's
black-and-white values
and sense of identity are
tested against the tides
of an increasingly complex
and diversified world,
which begs the question,
what value do our political
and cultural ideologies have
if they don't help us function
in our day-to-day lives?
To find out, we need to
examine the work of someone
that Hank Hill would probably
ask to leave his barbecue
but whose ideas he might
ultimately agree with,
Henri Lefebvre was a French...
(Hank screams)
Marxist...
philosopher...
(Hank screams)
who also likely preferred a nice glass
of room temperature red
wine to a nice cold Bud.
In his work, "The Critique
of Everyday Life",
Lefebvre tried to bring Marxist theory
into the experiences of
everyday, working-class people.
He became increasingly
frustrated with intellectuals
who seemed more interested
in pontificating
about the values of the working class
than actually listening to
the experiences of workers.
He used the example of
an urban intellectual
strolling the French countryside,
lamenting the plight of the peasant farmer
without ever experiencing the hard labor
it takes to work the land
or the centuries of cultivation
it took to shape it.
Because the everyday is
where most life happens,
it's a site of transformative conflict
worth taking seriously.
More than anything, he thought
that because capitalism
is constantly reproducing
itself via the everyday,
revolutionizing our day-to-day existence
was a precondition for any
type of future utopian society.
Now, Hank is definitely not a Marxist.
- I hate communists.!
All they do is boss people around!
- Sounds like you, Uncle Hank.
- [Michael] But he is a working-class guy
whose livelihood is often put in jeopardy
by the forces of capitalism.
He swears undying loyalty
to his boss and mentor,
Buck Strickland,
even though he delegates
most of the actual work
of running the shop to Hank,
while he spends his time
drinking, gambling and philandering.
Hank only stands up to his boss
when his Immoral ways
threatened to rub off on Bobby.
But this isn't the only
time Hank struggles
against the forces of the free market.
When the corporate superstore Mega Lo Mart
threatens to put Strickland
Propane out of business,
Hank lament the takeover
of local economies
by these corporate behemoths.
- The only place you can
find a main street these days
is in Disneyland, and just
try to buy a gun there.
- [Michael] And when that same superstore
threatens the quality of
the town's meat supply,
he even goes so far as to
join a hippie-infested co-op
just to get quality steaks.
It's clear that Hank
is willing to put aside
his conservative reputation
when it comes to meeting
the everyday needs
of his family and community.
When a major back injury
keeps him away from work,
he not only applies for
worker's compensation...
- Worker's comp! Do I
look like a hobo to you?
- [Michael] He even joins a yoga studio.
- Yoga?
Isn't that a cult?
- [Michael] Above all,
Hank values hard work,
and while this may sometimes blind him
to how much his own labor is
being exploited by his boss,
it also makes him keenly aware
of the needs of other working-class
folks in his community.
These people may have a multitude
of ideological differences,
but at the end of the day,
they have more in common with each other
than they do with Mega Lo Mart
or other external forces,
like the government.
For example, when the public schools
are forced to teach sex education.
- What do you know about sexual relations?
- I don't know. Nothing much.
I'm a little worried about being a slut.
- [Michael] While these
forces may initially sway
some residents to their side,
by the end of the episode,
it's the sense of community that wins out
and brings the characters back together.
Like when Peggy makes hella bank
selling homes to hipsters
who want to live in a
diverse neighborhood,
but eventually she realizes
that she's been contributing
to the gentrification
that almost forced
Hank's coworker, Enrique,
out of his home.
So, she remedies the situation.
- I own my own house! I am a homeowner!
Now I pay mortgage instead of rent.
- Lefebvre might describe
this as the people of Arlen
exerting their "right to the city".
According to him, urban
space was not the product
of the private entity who may own it
or even the state authority
who may govern it;
instead, it is the product of the people
who inhabit the space.
The food being cooked,
the languages being spoken
and the cultures being displayed
are all part of what makes an urban
or even suburban space thrive.
While cities and
neighborhoods may be built
with the backing of capital interest
and ruled over by local
and federal governments,
above all, they're social experiments.
And while the people in
Arlen aren't often seen
squatting in vacant buildings
or chaining themselves to
construction equipment,
although they do occasionally
engage in direct action,
they assert their own right to the city
in many different ways.
These include legal methods,
like when a Hank joins the zoning board
to repeal a ban on high-flow toilets,
and some less than legal methods,
like when the residents tear down
a prefab house in their neighborhood
when it's structural integrity
threatens their own homes.
While the majority of
the population of Arlen
has key demographics in common,
the protagonists of the
show are not in the business
of imposing their worldview
onto the town as a whole.
They simply want to be
able to live their lives
in the way that best suits them
while also looking out
for the collective good
of the community.
They may scoff at environmentalist hippies
or poke fun at gay rodeo clowns,
but they ultimately want to create a space
where all people can
live their best lives.
A lot has changed since "King
of the Hill" went off the air.
The political climate in the country
has become just a tad bit more polarized.
And with the ever-growing
influence of social media,
political identities are
being formed in an arena
that is far removed from
everyday, in person interactions.
It's never been easier to
avoid your cousin Jason
at family functions because he spammed you
with flat earther videos in your DMs.
When you don't have to
physically interact with someone
with differing viewpoints,
it's much easier to write them off,
and this is precisely where
we can still glean some wisdom
from "King of the Hill".
Because, at first glance,
it's easy to assume
the show's message is the importance
of putting aside our preconceived notions
about people we don't know,
and then working with them
to create communities that benefit us all.
And on its face, it may seem like this
"finding common ground" narrative
is pure political fantasy.
But what the Hill family
and their neighbors show us
is that our everyday
beliefs matter in big ways.
So while we might think of exploring
various political ideologies
online as a type of cosplay,
it can have real effects
on our personal lives
and, ultimately, upon
our wider communities.
It's not an either/or between
the everyday or the political,
but a both/and
in which these spheres
are inextricably linked,
which means that if we're open-minded
and kind to our fellow Redditors,
we're helping to shape
a kinder world offline.
But if we're being vengeful,
ideological dicks on social media,
we're creating an echo chamber
that encourages a vibe
of vengeful dickishness
to spread its wings in the real world.
Overall, King of the Hill's focus
on the politics of everyday life
and the way it shows us
how to use these politics
to assert our right to our own spaces
earns it a Wisecrack certified
label of pretty deep.
But what do you all think?
Are we reading too much into a show
that spends a significant
amount of its air time
on scenes like this?
- Yep.
- Or can the lives of
these animated Texans
teach us all how to live simpler,
yet more fulfilling lives?
Let us know in the comments,
and thanks as always
to our amazing patrons
for all your support.
And don't forget to check out
our new, updated Patreon page.
Also, be sure to check out our
new stream, Wisecrack Live,
right here every Thursday.
Smash that subscribe button
like it's an empty can of Alamo beer,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching. Later.
(upbeat electronic music)